continue our coverage of calls for
police reform in america those calls
all across the country echo protests
that took place in chicago after the
death of laquan mcdonald
more than five years ago in 2014 the
black 17 year old was shot
16 times by a white police officer later
a federally enforceable court order
mandated police reforms
in chicago adriana diaz looks at whether
there's been progress adriana good
morning what'd you learn
good morning tony as you said laquan
mcdonald was killed in 2014 but it
wasn't until last
year that the court order mandating
reforms known as the consent decree
took effect now training is up but
critics say
that racial bias has not changed and
that chicago police is dragging its feet
protests raged so fiercely in chicago
after george floyd's death
the city raised its bridges to cut off
crowds
baked into their anger was deja vu the
same demands followed laquan mcdonald's
death in 2014.
[Music]
[Applause]
we've been here time and time and time
again
are karen winter's grand nephew pierre
lory was killed by chicago police in
2016.
she and civil rights attorney craig
futterman sued the city
and are now working with police on
reforms
have they been successful it's early in
the it's early
the 236-page consent decree mandated
changes in police use of force
training and officer wellness but so far
cpd has missed
70 percent of the deadlines and
continues to struggle to conduct
meaningful community engagement
according to an independent auditor
we're seeing the same stuff in the
street
black people still being killed still
being abused
still a culture of denial of an impunity
can bias be eliminated within the system
through reforms or
is it time to scrap what's in place and
think differently
everyone has a bias of some sort but
it's about what you do with that
information
and dealing with that and i think the
training teaches us how to deal with
the bias deputy superintendent barbara
west says reforms
like increased training are working i
don't want him arrested i just need him
out of here
time is money they rolled out this
virtual reality training for recruits
which an instructor demonstrated sir i
need to see your hand sir
sir i need to see your hands when you
actually put yourself in a situation
all the training starts to kick in a
little bit more annual use of force
training is now mandatory
before west says officers could go
decades without a refresher
and use of force is down 34 since laquan
mcdonald's death
but a closer look at the numbers shows
black and hispanic people
are just as likely to be on the
receiving end despite a violent father's
day weekend
overall crime is at a five-year low but
blacks and hispanics account for 91
percent
of arrests a percentage that hasn't
budged in four years
why has the racial makeup of the people
being arrested not gunned down if you've
been reforming
so if you think about where our calls
for service come from they do come from
neighborhoods that are maybe
predominantly african-american and
latino what we've actually seen up until
very very recently
is how can we do the least amount
possible to check a box to get out from
under this
how has this experience been for you on
a personal level
seeing the changes people are crying out
for being a woman in uniform but also
being a black woman
sure you know first when i take this off
you know i'm a black woman and i have
black children
but in terms of what we're trying to do
as a police department i know it's the
right thing
but winter says change is taking too
long
you know this train that's coming get it
get on and get out of his way
winters and futterman are both part of a
new task force with police reviewing use
of force
now while cities like los angeles have
seen positive change after their own
consent decrees
don't expect one in minneapolis under
the trump administration the department
of justice
has been critical of them anthony
adriana diaz reporting for us thanks
adria